jim cameron is one of those
filmmakers who
you know is is designing the plane
as it's flying in such a brilliant way
and uh i you know i've got to know him
over the years and just in awe
of the way his brain works and uh so
yeah it's it's a big component
can you speak a little bit more to him
in terms of uh because you're such a
fascinating person
because you care a lot about technology
you care a lot about the cutting edge of
technology
so how does he a creator
a director
build the plane while it's flying like
what's the role of innovation in this
whole process
well um
so i never made a film with jim i'm just
a huge fan and got to know him
um and john landau his producing partner
and one of the things that just
fascinates me about jim is so he makes
titanic and there's a bunch of
underwater cameras and things that they
need that don't exist
so he goes and invents them
and
you know has a good grasp of engineering
and has not only the imagination but the
ability to lead a team to build them
um i got to go down early when they were
shooting avatar
at a warehouse i think it was where they
were shooting and as they were
explaining to me
how they were capturing it and that they
could go back later because they created
the environment
it blew my mind and i said okay this is
truly
people talk about a a big leap this
certainly is one so
he has continued
to push the envelope
in terms of the art of the possible and
i i just think he's an incredible genius
in that way
you